[Musique]
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui dans science clic entropie
et flèche du temps observant les deux
images suivantes
la première représente une structure
précise une pomme la deuxième ne
présente aucune structure elle est
homogène
imaginons maintenant que l'on génère une
troisième image en choisissant au hasard
la couleur de chaque pixel
une fois l'image générée on la compare
avec les deux précédentes à laquelle de
ces deux images la nouvelle image
ressemble-t-elle le plus visuellement
l'image aléatoire ressemble davantage à
l'image numéro 2 homogène toutes deux ne
présente aucune structure particulière
contrairement à la pomme si l'on
continue de générer de nouvelles images
aléatoire la plupart d'entre elles
ressembleront davantage à l'image numéro
deux la probabilité de créer au hasard
une image de pomme est très faible en
général on obtiendra plutôt une image
désordonnée sans structure et donc
homogène
c'est cette propriété de ressembler à
quelque chose d'aléatoire d'homogène que
l'on appelle l'entropie ici l'image
numéro 2 possède davantage d'entropie
car elle a plus de chances de ressembler
à une image aléatoire
[Musique]
dans notre univers l'entreprise est
défini de la même façon l'univers est
composée d'atomes qui peuvent s'agencer
de multiples façons et certains de ses
agencements semble homogène comme un gaz
alors que d'autres présentent des
structures comme un glaçon ou une pomme
si l'on imagine générés aléatoirement un
nouvel agencement en choisissant au
hasard la position et la vitesse des
atomes
on a davantage de chance de tomber sur
un agencement homogène qui ressemble un
gaz plutôt qu'à une pomme ou un glaçon
on dit donc que le gaz a davantage
d'entropie car il ressemble plus souvent
à une distribution aléatoire
plus précisément l'entropie d'un objet
est un nombre qui va compter parmi tous
les agencements possible ce qui
ressemble à notre objet l'idée est qu'un
autre échelle le manque de précision de
nos mesures et la très grande quantité
d'atomes nous empêche de différencier
ces configurations et les unes des
autres
bien qu'elles soient rigoureusement
différentes à l'échelle microscopique à
notre échelle elles semblent toutes
identiques pour mieux comprendre
observons ces deux images lorsqu'on les
regarde de très près on distingue la
couleur de chaque pixel
il est donc possible de les différencier
l'une de l'autre mais si on les regarde
maintenant de plus loin les détails
précis de chaque image ne sont plus
visibles
nous ne percevons que les formes et les
couleurs et les deux images semblent
désormais identique pour revenir à la
physique
l'entropie du glaçon est donc plus
faible que celle du gaz car il existe
beaucoup plus de configuration qui
ressemble au gaz plutôt qu aux glaçons
l'entropie mesure ainsi la marge de
liberté que possèdent les atomes elle
nous indique si notre objet nécessite
une configuration précise ou alors s'il
peut fluctuer à travers de nombreuses
configurations tout en gardant la même
apparence
dans un système de faibles entre pie ix
comme un glaçon les molécules d'eau
n'ont pas beaucoup de liberté
elles n'ont accès qu'à très peu de
configuration précise et leur agitation
est très faible ce qui explique que le
glaçon et froid al'inverse dans un
système d'entropie élevé comme de la
vapeur les molécules sont beaucoup plus
libres et peuvent fluctuer à travers de
nombreuses configurations différentes
elles sont très agités d'où la
température élevée
intuitivement la notion d'entropie va
donc permettre entre autres de
caractériser les états de la matière
solide liquides ou gaz
lorsqu'on fait bouillir de l'eau par
exemple l'énergie qu'on lui apporte la
chaleur va permettre d'augmenter son
entropie c'est-à-dire de délier les
molécules qui la composent leur donner
un comportement plus aléatoire et
désordonnée est ainsi passée sous une
face d'entropie plus élevé la vapeur la
notion d'entropie est donc très utile en
physique et en chimie notamment pour
caractériser les états de la matière
mais comme on l'a vu avec l'exemple des
images la notion est beaucoup plus
fondamentale et peut s'étendre à une
multitude d'autres domaines en
mathématiques
l'entropie de shannon mesure la quantité
d'informations que contient un objet par
exemple un texte
un texte répétitif contient peu
d'informations car il suffit d'indiquer
la formule qui se répète pour le décrire
entièrement al'inverse un texte plus
aléatoire moins structurés contient
beaucoup d'informations car notre seule
possibilité pour le décrire et
d'indiquer tous les caractères un parent
[Musique]
en informatique
l'entropie algorithmique est assez
similaire et mesure le temps que
mettrait un ordinateur a généré l'objet
qui nous intéresse plus l'objet contient
d'information - il est possible de
compresser le code qui le décrit l'idée
d'entropie mêmes utilisés dans l'étude
de la biodiversité car elle permet de
mesurer l'étendue des variations à
l'intérieur d'un ensemble
elle est également utile dans l'étude
des systèmes chaotique pour caractériser
leur comportement imprédictible
aléatoire comme par exemple le fait que
sur le long terme un double pendule
puisse être affectée par une toute
petite perturbation
enfin l'étude des trous noirs permet
également de leur attribuer une entropie
qui mesure la quantité d'informations
qu'ils ont avalé l'entropie d'un trou
noir est distribué à sa surface et plus
ils capturent d'information en absorbant
de nouveaux objets plus la surface du
trou noir ses larges
pour finir l'entropie joue également un
rôle crucial dans notre compréhension du
temps et plus particulièrement à propos
du sens dans lequel se produisent les
transformations pour comprendre
imaginons les deux configurations
suivante d'une part un ballon de
baudruche est ouvert à l'intérieur d'une
boîte et le ballon contient un gaz avec
une forte pression d'autre part on
imagine le même ballon ouvert mais cette
fois ci le gaz est répartie
équitablement à l'intérieur de la boîte
[Musique]
en supposant que la boîte évolue
spontanément peut-on deviner l'ordre
chronologique dans lequel se produisent
ces deux situations
est ce que le gaz était d'abord
comprimer dans le ballon et a eu
tendance à s'échapper au cours du temps
ou est-ce qu à l inverse le gaz était
initialement homogène et aurait eu
tendance à venir ce comprimé dans le
ballon à priori notre expérience
quotidienne nous donne l'intuition que
le gaz cette échappée du ballon qu'ils
auraient plutôt tendance à se diffuser
car revenir spontanément à l'intérieur
en général on a l'intuition que les
systèmes physiques ont tendance à
s'homogénéiser au cours du temps que les
tensions comme la pression dans le
ballon ont tendance à se relâcher
si l'on met un objet show en contact
avec un objet froid on s'attend par
exemple à ce que leur température
s'égalisent progressivement
pourtant à l'échelle microscopique les
deux états avant et après ne semble rien
présenté de particuliers on a du mal à
comprendre pourquoi le phénomène se
produirait forcément dans un sens plutôt
que dans l'autre c'est sur ce point que
la notion d'entropie va être crucial on
a vu précédemment que l'entropie d'un
objet est d'autant plus grande que
l'objet semble homogène à notre échelle
le deuxième état homogène possède donc
davantage d'entropie que le premier et
c'est précisément pour cette raison que
le processus se produit dans ce sens
plutôt que dans l'autre lorsqu'on laisse
un système évolué spontanément son
entropie a tendance à augmenter rendant
le système de plus en plus homogène au
cours du temps l'entropie d'un système
isolé a toujours tendance à augmenter
mais derrière ce principe très forts se
cache en réalité une explication simple
logique et intuitive pour la comprendre
reprenons notre analogie du début devant
nous une image structuré qui représente
une pomme à chaque instant on imagine
faire fluctuer légèrement la couleur des
pixels de l'image de façon aléatoire et
on observe son évolution au cours du
temps à l'échelle microscopique l'image
fluctue et va peu à peu s'éloigner de sa
configuration initiale
progressivement elle va parcourir de
multiples configurations différentes
en passant au hasard d'une configuration
à une autre
mais un autre échelle l'image de la
pomme semble progressivement s'estomper
elle devient de plus en plus homogène
jusqu'à ressembler parfaitement à
l'image grise que l'on avait vu au
départ en fluctuant au hasard petit à
petit l'image de la pomme est devenu de
plus en plus aléatoire et comme on l'a
vu au début de la vidéo une image dans
les pixels sont aléatoires à une très
forte probabilité d'être homogène dans
notre univers le phénomène est similaire
les atomes sont agités et leur
répartition microscopique fluctue
constamment passant spontanément d'une
configuration à une autre si l'on attend
suffisamment longtemps
la structure de l'univers est donc de
plus en plus aléatoire à l'échelle
microscopique et comme on l'a vu une
structure aléatoire a le plus souvent
tendance à être homogène au fil des
transformations notre univers s'estompe
peu à peu et ces structures se fondent
tandis que son entropie globales ne
cesse d'augmenter
l'entropie de l'univers mesure la
progression de son homogénéisation au
cours du temps
[Musique]
pour conclure
l'entropie est un concept fascinant bien
que très concrète et physique permettant
de caractériser les états de la matière
et leur transformation
elle semble finalement reposer sur des
idées très simple en particulier
l'entropie explique la flèche du temps
le sens dans lequel évolue l'univers par
une simple logique de probabilité
[Musique]
fondamentalement les atomes peuvent être
répartis dans l'univers de plein de
façons différentes
mais de notre point de vue certaines de
ces configurations se ressemblent et en
particulier celles qui sont les plus
homogènes
comme il en existe davantage en
fluctuant peu à peu l'univers va
naturellement les adopter sur le long
terme
aujourd'hui la question se pose de
savoir si l'univers finira par être
complètement homogène
en effet on peut imaginer qu'en
augmentant sans cesse son entropie
finissent par atteindre un maximum que
l'univers atteignent finalement un
équilibre et que la notion de flèche du
temps disparaissent car seuls les
fluctuations microscopique subsisterait
cela dit l'univers est en expansion et
les phénomènes de relativité générale
liée à sa géométrie permettrait
peut-être de s'opposer à ce scénario de
mort thermique
[Musique]
m